we've got 6798
minus
3359 so let's see how far we can get
with the subtraction
so immediately when we go into the ones
place we're going to try to subtract a 9
from an 8. so we really immediately
reach a little bit of a stumbling block
and to see what our options are here in
terms of regrouping i'm going to rewrite
both of these numbers so i'm going to
rewrite
6798 literally so this is equal to 6000
that's this right over here that's 6 000
plus 700
plus
plus 90
plus eight
plus
plus 8 minus all of this so minus
so i could do it i could subtract each
of the places so i could say this is
going to be minus
3 000. so minus
minus
50 a 5 in a tens place is just 50
minus 9
minus
minus 9. so there here we're just
explicitly showing what those place
values represent a 6 in the thousands
place is 6 000. a 3 in the hundreds
place is 300. but let's go back to our
problem we wanted to subtract a 9 from
an 8 well
that's a little bit of a stumbling block
but what if we could take some of the
value from some of these and give it to
the 8. in particular we could go one
place value up to the 90 and what if we
were to take 10 from the 90. so let's do
that if we were to take 10 from the 90
the 90 becomes 80 but we don't want to
change the value of the entire number so
we're going to give that 10 to this 8.
so we're going to give so we gave we're
going to give that 10 to the 8 we're
essentially regrouping right over here
and then that 8 can become an 18. notice
i did not change the value of the number
i just essentially changed how i
represented it instead of saying it's 6
000 plus 700 plus 90 plus 8 i'm just
saying that it's 6 000 plus 700 plus 80
plus 18. those are both going to give
you 6798
but now it becomes a little bit easier
for us to actually subtract now if we
subtract
now if we subtract i have 18 minus 9
which is 9. i have 80 not 90 now i have
80 minus 50 which is 80 minus 50 which
is 30 and these are all positive this is
plus nine this is a positive thirty
eighty minus fifty is thirty i have
seven hundred minus three hundred which
is four hundred and i have six thousand
minus three thousand which is three
thousand
three thousand so this is literally
going to be three thousand plus four
hundred plus thirty plus nine or three
thousand four hundred thirty nine now
how would you do it if you didn't wanna
write it out like this and this is where
you'll see kind of a shorthand notation
this is often called borrowing so you
say look i got an 8 in the ones place i
want to take
a 10 from this 90. so it's going to
become
it's going to become an 80 but we'll
just write it as an 8 because it's in
the tens place this 8 represents the 80
and i'm going to give that 10 to the
ones place so 10 plus 8 is
10 plus 8 is 18. and now you can
subtract 18 minus 9 is 9. 8 minus 5 is
three
seven minus three is four
six minus three
is three three thousand four hundred and
thirty-nine